for those of us who have never had a  chance to visit the club what made it so  special to you and all these other  comedians well it's funny to say I was  there last night to the show uh it's sad  it's like a New York staple it's had  like four locations fun fact started as  a cabaret Club in Chelsea and they did  comedy on Monday and then comedy was so  successful they said we'll do it Monday  and Tuesday and then they just said [ __ ]  it we're going all comedy I saw Paul  Mooney there I saw Doug Stanhope there  and he saw David tell in the back and he  goes Dave what are you doing here and  David tell goes well I heard a white  voice coming out of Caroline so I had to  see who it was they were they were  booking a lot of black accidents yeah so  uh you know Dave's the funniest guy on  the planet so yeah so many great  memories I hooked up with a waitress  there years ago uh good times good times  love it